foreign
the Isle of Mull in the Hebrides just
off the west coast of Scotland
the island has a Timeless Beauty
Washed by the natural rhythms of weather
and the seasons
but not always
the one weekend in the Autumn the mall
rally Roars into town
the rally is the longest toughest and
most popular closed road race in Britain
around 150 cars compete day and night on
sinuous strips of tarmac that speeds
well above 100 miles an hour
this year is its 50th drivers and fans
come from across the country yet it is
frequently won by locals what do you
think the rally brings to the island
uh lots of money a nice Buzz a great
atmosphere the last bit of fun before
the winter let's say it's in they reckon
it brings over a million pounding it is
a thrilling sport an Indulgence a
Pastime based around the internal
combustion engine carbon dioxide is
being emitted for fun
so I thought I'd have a go
press the launch button here we go
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
oh well
I'm allowed in the co-driver's seat for
what is known appropriately as the
Shakedown stage
dress rehearsal under rally conditions
Before the Race proper because
whoa John tells me during racing they
use about a liter of fuel every mile
that's a lot of petrol being used in
this game hey
[Music]
oh hello hedge
what we do Tom is we work out the
average fuel consumption that's expected
to be used by a rally car in liters and
we use conversion figures to translate
that into carbon equivalent and we
offset based on that for the competition
either for the competitors competing or
Spectators or the teams whatever way we
want to do it
they're all setting around half the
emissions from the competitors and The
Spectators calculated at 46 tons of
carbon dioxide that's similar to the
climate change impact of driving an
average car for 27 years I suppose the
question in the end some people would
say that yes you're giving this a
license to continue maybe for the
climate it will be better if it stopped
yes and we could say that about lots of
human activity and lots of sports you
know as I see the perception of
Motorsport because they're noisy cars
they are consuming fuel but you know if
you think about the carbon footprint of
golf or football we're all creating a
carbon footprint and it's good that
we're taking responsibility
I can safely say that was the most
exciting and somewhat scary thing I've
ever done in my life
quite extraordinary obviously the
adrenaline taps just straight on
and now we're gonna go again
[Music]
the rallies carbon sponge will be a
forest on the mainland trees absorb
carbon dioxide as they grow it's one of
the main ingredients in wood
well we're in the middle of a vast
planting area but be careful not to step
on the new trees quite a small at the
moment so more Forest means more carbon
captured and this year's mull rally paid
Highland carbon for a little under an
acre to be planted and cared for it
would be spectacular this will all be
native broadleaf along the Lower Side of
the bank starting from Willow and Alder
and working its way up through
Aspen and Oak and so on up and up to
conifers upon on the upper reaches how
much scrutiny and certification is are
on these projects to make sure they're
actually going to lock up the carbon
that they promise
very high level of scrutiny so all of
these projects are third party inspected
there's an inspection after the project
is completed which has already happened
there's then uh an inspection after the
first five years and then every 10 years
after that it's not just verifying the
trees are there it's there's enough
carbon stored within those trees on the
site
some drivers believe the whole Sport's
long-term survival rests on making this
change if you look at Formula One you
look at the World Rally Championship
World Rally cross Championship all those
are adapting new technology whether it's
all electric whether it's hybrid and I
think people are realizing at the
Grassroots at the national level of the
sport that if we don't change there's
not going to be a future of the sport
for ourselves in five ten years and for
the Next Generation
[Applause]
Motorsport is part of the entertainment
industry
[Applause]
can offsetting and Technical fixes stop
it becoming a relic of History